the big I think you kind of know you
live on an active volcanoes the
situation is involving our by power in
some cases even faster than that
the fish is opening up let's go people
are losing their homes they're losing
their livelihoods when you know
everybody on this road you're like a
family you know and just
[Music]
is tragic in another way it's really
beautiful because it's it's absolute
destruction and creation at the same
time the Island of Hawaii after the
eruption of one of the world's most
active volcanoes Mount Kilauea this was
Cal Poly Street inside the evacuation
zone molten rock advancing an utterly
unstoppable force so we've just come
down into the Nalani Estates area and
happened across this incredible scene
lava creeping down the road
burning art property and trees as it
comes into contact some residents have
come to take risks and to marvel but for
others this is an awful moment mum and
daughter Laurie and Alyssa Cruz comfort
one another if the lava keeps moving
like this their home will be gone soon
have you got a call to evacuate yes are
you ready to go I'm ready
I have already evacuated everything I
just came down to say goodbye to my
neighborhood for last time when you know
everybody on this road you're like a
family you know and just did you expect
it to ever get this bad no not really I
didn't know what to expect but I was
hoping that my house wasn't gonna get
destroyed but I guess God had other
plans
the lava starts flowing more quickly
steam shoots into the air the locals say
it's time to move we're going back
quickly now because a fish is opening up
let's go dusk isn't far away the road
starts buckling in the heat despite all
of this some of the residents managed to
remain philosophical it is tragic and in
another way it's really beautiful
because it's it's absolute destruction
and creation at the same time the wind
shifts so he put gas masks on as we walk
to a different vantage point it's an
extraordinary sight multiple fissures
merging lava fields the power of Mount
Kilauea on full display the community
has no choice but to watch wait and hope
that they don't lose everything
[Music]
taking a helicopter to the coast we were
guided by a local resident and pilot
Casey Allen all right now we're on the
southeast point of the Big Island Hawaii
climbing up to go where we're allowed to
open the doors for a better view this
thick white cloud looks beautiful but
it's dangerous when lava hits the sea
water it produces steam full of
hydrochloric acid and tiny shards of
glass from up here you can also get a
sense of the scale of these flows some
of them have merged and some of them are
moving at speeds of up to 300 meters an
hour in the distance new lava spews from
cracks in the earth on the ground this
is the newest concern lava
advancing on a geothermal power station
authorities are worried that there could
be a chemical reaction here which might
put more noxious gas into the air it's
yet another thing for the National Guard
who are taking us to see the area to
worry about
we're following a tactical vehicle
Humvee with Hawaii National Guard
soldiers what they're doing is they're
part of our roving patrols that are
going through the evacuation zones
on Hawaii's Big Island they're trying to
track the fishes that keep opening up as
Mount Kilauea erupts the situation is
evolving almost hour by hour in some
cases even faster than that we drive
through the jungle to our first stop a
still steaming lava flow a situation in
this part of the island remains really
unpredictable this huge lava flow
arrived in just a few hours and it
covered this road completely blocking
what could be a really important
evacuation route hey Jeff
check the cloud our escorts are
anxiously monitoring the nearby plume of
toxic lava haze the wind has shifted
blowing it towards us I don't know what
it's like to breathe in hydrochloric
acid and glass shards but I really don't
want to find out time to leave
the guards want to check the roads lots
of them damaged beyond use so enough
weight on this will probably cause the
road to collapse and it looks like it's
gotten an inch or two wider maybe an
inch wider in the last 24 hours we move
further into the evacuation zone to
investigate a newly expanded fissure the
heat and pressure from the lava changing
the ground below our feet it is an eerie
sight huge cracks have opened up in the
ground
sulfur dioxide pouring out killing the
vegetation around it for good reason
most of the residents who live here have
evacuated they returned to check on
their property and somehow are pragmatic
you live on a volcano so I guess you
know as people that live in tornado
belts and flood zones they rebuild
others have stayed and pay little
attention to the danger
sir this is this rocker you think of it
like an Eminem with the Arkansas melted
and I know
basky on the inside at this community
center nearby locals gather to exchange
information
there's more than one feeling about
what's happening here people are losing
their homes they're losing their
livelihoods their job like farms and
whatnot are being burnt it's surreal
it's a it's a mix of emotions it's it's
terrifying it's beautiful
the ancestors before us our grandparents
went through this also so it's like you
know for our for our generation we never
taught it but it did so we're not
leaving Pune people
[Music]
before anyone can rebuild all of this
has to end but scientists say there's no
way to tell when this will happen
it's an unfolding unpredictable and
open-ended crisis the earthquakes
eruptions and lava flows continue
Kilauea isn't finished yet
[Music]